best friend's trip this is gonna be
iconic
you do understand this is a work trip
for me Audrey I got you look at me
you're thinking about a dick damn it
you're right look at me look at me look
at me now I love a grand Adventure I
heard that if you keep up with Chinese
businessmen they respect you more
play is it a condom you look like you've
had a lot of things in your I'm
not a lot of things just one thing but
maybe different varieties of that one
thing look at me look at me go figure
[Music]
if you do not know where you come from
how do you know who you are I'm just a
garbage American who only speaks English
and a little Golem
en do you guys have that here yeah we
have it's the whole over the world y'all
calling me crazy let's just be adults
are you horny
sex isn't shameful it's beautiful like
the noises oh
there's some in this house
I'm not racist you don't like Boba and
you never an Asian guy damn still
when I masturbate I sometimes fantasize
about Splinter he's Asian he's a rat
he's a good father